how do we strengthen in bulletproof our
immune system that is a topic for today
first thing is what is your immune
system it's basically your defenses it's
your army
it's your military to fight off the bad
guys the pathogens pathogens our
microbes that cause disease the
derivation of the word immune comes from
the Latin word immunise which means
exempt from public service now that's
interesting now if you break down this
concept it really means protected or
free against insults harm or disease so
basically your immune system protects
you against disease so the immune system
is like immigration so if something
foreign enters the body it has to go
through the Airways it has to go maybe
through the digestive system and has to
get the stamp of approval from
immigration and that's what your immune
system does it's rule it's constantly
scanning to see if you are a foreign
entity that could cause harm or if
you're part of the body and once it tags
you is a foreign thing that could
threaten the body it'll automatically
send in the defenses and that's what
we're gonna cover next there are three
main barriers for the immune system you
have the skin so you have all these
friendly bacteria on your skin that
actually help protect you against
foreign invaders you also have a fat
layer that protects you and you have
certain acids that protect you on the
skin then you have the mucous lining in
your gut through the Airways through the
sinuses that also capture and engulf
foreign particles or microbes
inflammation is another barrier that
your body puts up to protect itself the
main cells in your immune system are the
white blood cells compared to the red
blood cells that have a different
function
you also have in addition to white blood
cells you have friendly bacteria that
help you as well and the name of the
friendly bacteria collectively is called
the microbiome or flora and those
microbes help you many ways from
absorption of nutrients to recycling a
bile to immune defenses just one
things they do as a strategy is ill
they'll make it so there's just not
enough space for a pathogen to live and
they will make it so there's not enough
food for that pathogen to live so let's
talk about the defenses of your immune
system the white blood cells
it makes acid to dissolve and kill
microbes and pathogens it will secrete
poison to kill off these microbes it
releases free radicals it will make
hydrogen peroxide you've probably seen
that before will you take prejudice
Brock side and you put it on an open cut
it just dissolves it bubbles up and just
kills off the microbes through oxidation
our white blood cells actually make
enzymes to help break down and dissolve
microbes now I already mention this one
our microbes compete for food or space
but the white blood cells generate mucus
and inflammation and so these pathogens
get caught up in this mucus web and they
can't really do anything else it's like
quicksand
also our immune system has a memory
everything that's happening so
everything's in a database and it could
remember like so way down the road when
there's a microbe that actually comes
back in our body and their immune system
actually tags it because it has a memory
of that and it can destroy it so it
actually learns over time by being
exposed to these pathogens
that's called building up your immune
system and this is why as a child it's
not very healthy to keep a child just so
utterly sterile that they're never
exposed or they're never sick it's a
natural part of building the immune
system then we get to something called
the phagocyte that's part of our immune
system the phagocytes our cells that eat
things they devour microbes and they
have a ravenous appetite for not just
microbes and viruses and bacteria and
yeast and fungus but they will also eat
up dead cells and debris they are the
garbage disposal for things that we
don't want in our body just one liter of
blood has six billion of these guys now
an interesting thing about phagocytes is
that they're stimulated by acid and I
think this is why this is just my guess
why
when people take a lot of synthetic
vitamin C ascorbic acid certain people
get results even with synthetic vitamin
C simply because the acid I would
recommend just consume the apple cider
vinegar apple cider vinegar has been
known to acidify the body and speed up
phagocytosis
just like any acid so if you have a
choice
I would recommend the food based vitamin
C not the synthetic but use apple cider
vinegar to actually speed up
phagocytosis and another mechanism that
I want to mention that I didn't write
down and involve certain white blood
cells if certain white blood cells are
infected by a pathogen we have this
built-in mechanism that if the cell is
invaded it goes through something called
apoptosis where it killed itself off for
the benefit of the entire body because
if they let the microbes bleach into
their DNA and start reproducing then
they become the copy machine that just
makes the virus over and over and over
now on the flip side the bad guys the
pathogens also have their defences as
well they have the ability to block
vitamin D and they do it through the
vitamin D receptor because somehow they
know that vitamin D is so essential for
the control of your immune system that
they can block it they lower your
resistance to invading the cells and so
they can take it over the other thing
that these sneaky little pathogens do is
they can mimic your body tissue so
you're not recognized by the immune
system they're very sneaky that way
they can also hide in calcium little egg
loose little houses and this is why
antibiotics are not effective against
something called biofilm and that's a
whole different topic I put a video down
below for more information about that
but these microbes have gotten very very
smart another mechanism especially with
microbes like the mycoplasma that
doesn't have a cell wall they keep
moving they'll move into one joint in
the synovial fluid another joint and
then your immune system is trying to
attack them and they miss and so they
keep moving so you can't get them
another mechanism is they these microbes
have the ability to morph into different
structures so your immune system gets
confused okay so now let's talk about
what to do about it there's two things
you have things that weaken the immune
system and you have things that
strengthen the immune system now as far
as what weakens the immune system low
nutrient foods going in a diet that
creates nutritional deficiencies if you
take the pandemic the Spanish flu that
occurred in 1918 and you take a look at
what happened just before this pandemic
this spread of virus all over the world
that killed fifty to a hundred million
people what occurred right before that
is world warm one now what happened in
this war is you had this huge shift of
transportation of food you had rationing
you had the preserving of food a lot of
the soldiers were given things like
canned corn beef some foods had dog food
there just wasn't a lot of fresh
vegetables and food so when you do that
over a period of time you weaken the
immune system especially if you put
someone under a stressful state like
being in a war that is going to set the
person up for a susceptibility to having
a virus invading their body so when
you're low in vitamins trace minerals
minerals amino acids and fatty acids
especially you are more susceptible to
getting sick because of the fact that
the nutrient defense mechanism is
dependent on these nutrients but I mean
just think about a virus for example a
virus can't do anything to you it's not
alive unless it invades the cell wall
and goes right into your DNA and starts
to turn that thing into a copy machine
while it hijacks the the life force from
that cell now think about what I just
said it has to invade the cell wall okay
that cell wall is too late layers of fat
it's a bi lipid layer
of fat okay so this is another reason
why essential fatty acids are vital to
protect yourself you don't want to go on
a low-fat diet when you run down or sick
so fat in cholesterol by the way is very
important in a healthy immune system
cholesterol is an essential building
block for certain hormones like cortisol
for example cortisol is really important
in your immune system so if cortisol
does not have its building blocks
cholesterol
it can't be formed correctly and then
you have stress this is probably
equivalent to nutrient deficiencies in
fact in practice I don't remember one
case that came in that had some sickness
that didn't have some stress event occur
right before it so stress is a very key
factor and I'd put some links down below
for more information on how someone can
extract stress low sleep also sets you
up for being susceptible then it's
connected to stress as well and glucose
I just released a video on this one
point certain viruses are activated more
with glucose fuel versus other fuels so
you know about health Aikido and immuno
fasting for those of you that are new
and you don't know anything about it
check it out I put a link down below of
the exact diet that you need to be on to
have a very strong immune system but now
let's talk about what nutrients are
really vital in keeping your immune
system bulletproof at the top of the
list we have vitamin C and I'm not
talking about synthetic vitamin C and
talking about a vitamin C from food or a
food concentrate now nature vitamin C
always comes in a complex of many parts
not just one thing ascorbic acid but the
foods that are highest in vitamin c our
sauerkraut bell peppers berries green
leafy vegetables vitamin c has the power
to stimulate the production of more
white blood cells vitamin c is also
stored in large quantities in your
adrenal gland to actually help make
adrenal hormones now next one that's
equally as important vitamin d i've
talked about that in the slide right
before this vitamin d is
immune modulator it's not really even a
vitamin it's a hormone factor that
actually controls your immune system so
it has a function that goes way beyond
just making bone there's vitamin D
receptors in all of your white blood
cell and in your DNA and when I mean
modulate the immune system I mean has a
controlling factor over your immune
system and many people are deficient
about them indi and they don't even know
it but it supports the t-cells okay
which are made by the thymus gland which
is like a training camp for white blood
cells it also protects against pathogens
and it actually makes these two
different things that have the capacity
to kill microbes very potent Lee so
vitamin D does a lot of different things
for your immune system next one in the
list that's very important is vitamin A
okay vitamin A provides the structural
integrity of the mucosal cells in the
sinus and their respiratory centers the
best source of vitamin A is cod liver
oil egg yolks butter is a good one
because it's the fat soluble vitamin and
by the way vitamin D is very hard to get
from food so the Sun would be probably
the best source or as a supplement zinc
is the most important trace mineral for
the immune system it actually can
increase t-cells and it does a lot of
other things for the immune system but a
lot of people are deficient in zinc but
zinc is very protective against viruses
garlic is hands down ranks number one in
potency for killing off viruses bacteria
yeast fungus mold is very very potent
next one is colloidal silver which is
basically silver particles in water it's
been around for a long time it starves
off the oxygen supply to certain
microbes so it's a very potent some
people use it as a nasal rinse and it
works really good but this is a very
potent antiviral as well and then olive
leaf olive leaf has been studied
extensively I put some links down below
for more information on that but this is
great as an anti viral into
we protect the immune system there's a
lot of other things that can protect the
immune system but from my viewpoint
these are the most powerful hey guys
well thanks for watching I know I gave
you a lot to take in but if you haven't
seen this video on stress check it out I
think you'll find it fascinating